good morning good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen we're glad you joined us for
this rise webinar contrasting tumor
invasion of antibody and remedy my name
is Jessica lavish of AB camp and I'll be
moderating today's question today's
educational web seminar is presented by
blabbers the leading scientific social
networking website and provide our
virtual events and webinars advances
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you today by ab cam as
an innovator in reagents and tools AB
camps purpose is to serve life science
researchers globally to achieve their
mission faster providing the research
and critical communities with tools and
scientific support we offer highly
validated biological binders and assays
to address important targets and
critical biological pathways to learn
more visit WWF cam comm so now let's get
started you can pose questions to the
speaker during the presentation while
they're still fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the Q&A box
which will open when you click the green
Q&A button at the lower left hand side
of the presentation window all questions
will be answered after the presentation
to enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you're
experienced technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problems by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left hand
side this is an educational webinar and
offers free continuing education credit
after the webinar is over please click
on the C e button located in the bottom
left-hand corner of your webpage and
follow the process of obtaining your
credit I now present today's speaker dr.
Ahn dr. Arnott's professor of molecular
medicine the Robert a Welch
distinguished University chair and
chemistry and director of the Texas
therapeutics Institute
at the Institute excuse me at the
University of Texas Health Science
Center at Houston his laboratory focuses
on cancer antibody drug resistance
mechanisms biomarkers for cancer
therapeutic antibodies an antibody drug
discovery targeting cancer and
infectious diseases he also directs the
therapeutic monoclonal antibody lead
optimization and development core
facility funded by the cancer prevention
and Research Institute of Texas
previously he served as chief scientific
officer epitome extinct and was director
of biologics research at Merck research
laboratory he is a fellow of the Society
for industrial microbiology and
biotechnology and is well published in
the field of antibody drug discovery
including the award-winning book
therapeutic monoclonal antibodies from
bench to clinic dr. Ahn will now began
his presentation hello everyone for
Jonny this webinar today so what I get
to do is to tell you a story about the
whole tumor can you Beijing ID body
immunity this is a pretty new field as I
go to slowly explain to you some of it
we should research activities from a
laboratory in collaboration with the
Joshua joshan so we know that innovation
of T cell immunity cell immunity is a
hallmark of a culture but we know later
about cutting visual for the humoral
immunity that's antibody immunity so the
is a clinically observed that the
antibody therapeutics are the human
resisted by the capture after treatment
therefore the tumor has a way to evade
antibody immunity it's also including
Auto antibodies targeting tumour source
advantages so the scientific question we
ask is are there
other lying magnums of a tumor invasion
of antibody annuity if that's the case
holy cataract - - the invasion of
antibody immunity so let's start by
reviews ID by the structure
everybody has it's a complex hydro
tettemer and with the molecular weight
of for more than 150 categories so
anybody's is composed of two distinct
sections or fragments you say the
warship structure has the variable aging
or fab fragment that's where antibody
gates its targets and there anybody has
FC domain that is a high vertical
uncalculated
the color calculation play a big role is
addaperle
a new effector function and as well as a
long half-life slightly body actually
calico engineering is became a major and
active field to modulate antibody a new
effector function uses a political body
design and everybody also engages the
civil cue receptor just mediate
compliment mediate so cellular
cytotoxicity which is responsible mostly
for the pectoral clearers at anybody's a
facility also you get FC gamma receptors
post kasia cells are the new cells that
also mediate a new mediated function
such as a DCC set for anybody to pedal
to cellular cytotoxicity add to add full
complexity everybody's is a DG also type
you have ID g VAR GG to register at IgG
for
differed
other types of live eg has differed mu
effective functions for Apple ID g1 is
actively engages a new system and I
digit 24 unless so igg3 has a very long
neck or so H is not a very stable so
it's not used for Silla to do everybody
design but a DG 1 2 & 4 has to be used
either saluting antibody drug
development last but not least
everybody's life is really also engaged
if we say they are in receptor that's
also know as a neonatal receptor on the
briber receptor let's wear contribute to
the long half-life of as anybody humor
everybody has about 21 days of half-life
in circulation so for summarize anybody
has two distinct segments the first
segment is the fact fragment that engage
the target and is a facility
he gave the immune system the fab
fragment and the if you say are linked
by this region called hydrogen so here
let's take our earthly body color tattoo
to map and also know as the Herceptin
which is a drug targeting her tool which
is a tyrosine kinase receptor so is the
over expressly about 30 to 35 percent of
a breast care patients SOTA tumor has to
be a very successful drug to for the
whole of expression breast care patients
so host her children might work in terms
the mode of action is the fiber fragment
he engaged the hurtful receptor by
inhibition of the her to signal a rank a
blog and he hit tumor cell growth
a top of that so the HSA part of is a
molecule ke gauges if it's a gamma
receptor in this case as well well
established that tattoo to map can
reduce the antibody titer to cellular
cytotoxicity
this is in my lab actually discovered a
new mode of action for for tributo map
it is because you say the catcher cell
over expresses her to try to to map is a
sub-portion fragment he gauges a hurtful
receptor if we see part of the officer
sadhu to map engaged if if the
government receptor are new cells or
effector cells such as a natural killer
cells so by a Depot by the engages a
physical receptor they'll activate is a
new cell then the new cell is created
satellites such as beautiful
gamma the eautiful gamma where he gauges
the usual ferragamo receptor as a
cashless cell which will activate the
transcription factor stead of wall so
first 42 said the wall bill Margaret to
nucleus that blocks a her true
subscription for this lecture the first
time they know that the how to receptor
down regulation by a to to lab is
actually engaged by the new effector
function so it's contributed by is a
part of the molecule also receiving you
my laboratory we discovered that the
seduced by my became not only you gauges
the ADC a so the immune factor function
that's anybody to padded cellular
cytotoxicity but also can you gauge a
DCP that's everybody to padded
phagocytosis so in this experiment I
show you what slides that if you
Legos are targeted sell that's the
highlighter expression brush Kasia
cell-cell light PT for civil forum and
the you label that fell on you that
color and value labels immunosuppressed
sell this case macrophage you gray and
you also need to activate the middle
fabric sell by use of Ferragamo at LPS
so I'll show you our left panel the
image you say i do - map can mediate the
focus are ptosis of Cascia cell by the
macrophage you say the red cell you
gulped by the blue or the gray
macrophage so the middle panel uses also
tab control you to not say that again
show you that the traditional map
actually July on it's a new vector
function for it's part of its efficacy
in KD offer higher to expression Cassius
cells and so this is a summarized here
so for traditional egg to work to block
tumor cell growth you have four
discovered mode of action so number wise
the ID buddy is the fact fragment of
lady buddy
he gauges a carousel that blog her too
sickly so that's a while mechanism but
more importantly if you say part of
Institute of land which immediate a DCC
a DCP and also her2 receptor down
regulation and adjust transcription
level also contributed to the mode of
action of a tattoo to map
so we knew if we lost her children
mother has been very successful drugs
for how her - especially breast Cashen
it's the cut of about 25% of the breast
cancer patients but we knew that only
about half of the 25% of the how to
overexposure breast carapace is
responsible treatment suggesting that
their primary resistance of breast Kasia
tool to this antibody and another fund
that is if the patient initially
responded fortitude remember treatment
eventually some of these patients will
develop relapse and the metastasis of
the Kesha whatever happens that Avani no
longer works suggesting that the cash or
actually in tumor developed a quadrille
resistance suppose the problem
resistance and the problem resistance
accounted for this actually became a
major clinical challenger for the
strategy arbitrator murder for hire
through breast cancer and so the
question we ask is so what's the
mechanism that the breast cancer drug
resistance both primary and quad
resistance to the strategic management
so while observation we we know if the
casual field is that is the vacuumer
progresses and the tubal mark
environment accumulate the mm piece
these are matrix metalloproteases that
we know that the Calavera body at the
head region and so so so we ask the
question so maybe this accumulation of
mm piece might be might play a role is
acquired also our primary resistance of
offered antibody try to to map for ha
her to express breast cancer
so let's take a back of to review occupy
the motivated cleavage of antibodies so
you laboratory we know that we can using
the protease Pepe that's actually added
Proteus produced papaya leather cat
slaves everybody is upper age you notice
the the upstream of suppose put a
suffered part in hatred ridges that
leaks antibodies together and this give
us the sub fragment we use this is
arbitrary all the time and they rated
similarly that Republic had D cleaved by
the mammalian Proteus pepsin and the
lower head of the antibody that's about
similar to the suffered apart that give
you the fab to fragment so we use that
also for
differed you know as a rage into four
different studies so if you review the
kinetics of the in somatic cleave is a
key Bunny the cleavage of the first
strand of the heavy chain is very fast
so it resolved to have a chase article
but it was the false try to claim the
first read actually resisted cleavage so
the cleavage of course if you you could
be the antibody with Proteus long enough
you will achieve complete cleavage so
this is suggesting that the hedge ratio
of the molecule is a critical we know
structurally the hedge region is very
flexible
let's give you the flexibility of thirty
buddy can you gauge a SATA juice and
this is also religious at and because of
the flexibility of the hedge raging we
cannot crystallize actually as you tire
and you talk to anybody
molecule so most of the antibody crystal
structures are based on sub fragment or
fab tool so the so the hydrogen is
almost like Achilles heel of the
antibody is such table to proteolytic
cleavage because of the structures
flexibility
so third of that are you literature mmm
peace such an image is two three seven
nine twelve thirty they can all clear
Valley Belize uses hydrogen at very
specific sites and if we also know some
of the proteins such as MEP seventeen I
a you know poor prognosis markers for
tumor progression and and so here my
collaborators the judge injection pH
paper at two and I showed the hatred
rages everybody so he judged is verified
this is IG g VAR h about 90 minutes
assets you notice the two systems that's
responsible for the truth of one part
that liquid to have a case together and
any Proteus cleavage side of thorium in
truth of your bond give you the fab to
for a minute I'll swim off the tooth
suffered apart give you the fat fragment
also you notice the number six
clearly son number six let's pretend to
Lucy that's actually cleaved by Pepsi so
give you the fabric true fragment that
overlaps with the Krivda side of m87
so while for the major tumor progression
related proteases mmm p7 so your
laboratory they can't generate this
antibody Haiti clave the Seco Heathcliff
Daddy bunny the other are the right
panel you say the you typed your control
you say you have the strategy map which
is ideally one and there is protein as
IgG was the proteolytically cleaved by
the protease a single cleavage so the
name is si IgG
assess data for cycle cleaved igg1 try
to to map
so after this the cleavage of first
riders IgG Atlas age the 30 body still
stage it has the because h3 of daddy
body are still has their two gathered
through the knob you whole metal
universe larger now converted apart so
we use this rages they did a self body
experiment is a panel you notice notice
that the postal you tagged antibody i do
- map and as a psycho cleavage try to to
map they kept by the the how hurtful
expecially Cassius LPG for sale for with
equal infinity you say the you PU has
say the body comes overlap so let's see
that the say go head cleavage did not
compromise the fabric portion of
molecules that you gauge the how to
receptor on cash your cells and
similarly your your cell you have
individual si you panel DS middle you
say the poses a new tags antibody and
the single credulity Bundy can you have
it about the 50% of cell growth so you
take this cell is a cell panel as left
you say post antibodies the cab you have
it a hurtful phosphorylation akt
phosphorylation at the ultra
phosphorylation suggesting a gap the
single cleavage did not compromise the
fat portion of ready body that we engage
the her two sig Lisa blog refer to
immediate signaling and then another
experiment of attested the impact of
will hate the cleavage are 30 buddy
ability to part
two different every state government
receptors and that measured earlier if
we say public molecule carry gauge the
physical receptors are new cells
you notice the panel be a data panel see
the cleavage of antibody of Sudoku map
you abolished the ID body stability
engages a physical receptor 2a and a
receptor 3 and over the product that the
receptors way is the major a physical
receptor a little K cells that was
possible for a DCC and a DCP that's
everybody depended to cetera substitute
accessory and antibody needed
phagocytosis which are measured earlier
so you peyote we did a unique for a BCC
I see the user I say we take a Akasha
cell in this case the whole 12
expression s Kos recache a cell line you
mix with the EMU effector cell it is a
human PBMC then you add the Utica to to
map that acai mediate about 80% of the
cell Kelly that's both a DCC and is a
DCP but if you cleave lightly by the
under hatred use the single cleaved
adg-1 try to to map you actually lost
the ADC selectively again suggesting
that the cleavage ready buddy
you abolished the MU if you say mediate
Liam you affect the function this is a
contribute to its lack of a body to F is
a gamma 3 receptor in new cells so you
put this antibodies into a simple little
graph model where you take a high her to
expressing breast cancer cell line PT
for say before and you trade with the
the Auto Club karate body as you would
expect to to move a girl
if you trade will you text the tragical
map
you said tumor or be blocked but if you
trade this is a single cliff to try to
to map the tumor inhibitor fracases
summer very deep III so in this case the
way we were able to dissect the mode of
action for tattoo to map with you 60% of
efficacy came from the FSA needed
effective function and the 40% came
Pharma how to signaling inhibition and
the ex vivo study of a tumor sample
showed that the post antibodies can die
rugged hurtful the separate level blocks
the first of all relation for her to a
Katie and Earth again suggesting that as
a h cleaved anybody is capable for
engages hydro receptor and blocks it
secondly that's actually a kata for
about a 40% of his a fxl phonetic body
so one way I feel exactly is we can do
is a to Eugenie rightly bodies that is
resistant to protein it in cleavage so
this is actually active field so
judgment Josh's and is a 2d is a
platform that there are virtually
certain web I'm the other antibodies can
be constructed with high degrees
photolytic resistors another mapping in
we can we can overcome with supported
acclivity research is that we can get
into antibody that recognizes the
cleavage site so this this record is a
this this at embody recognize the
critical site will provide a new test is
a that can rescue the loss of FSA factor
function so they could CODIS anybody
rescue antibody you can imagine at
regenerate
is this this pretty like cleavage
anybody we need a secluded meal epitope
so there's a minor amount of difference
between you tell anybody the kravecki
buddy presented Charlie DeGeneres the
passive agent so so this was actually
just reduction collaboration visit
Potomac snow part of Abraham so we tried
ultimately from Mosab coma from fridge
library and local sources inside with
rabid web map that should give us the
best anybody's Africa I can distinguish
the menu difference between it is
created by the on social and from new
tact antibody so all right you can tell
that if the antibody got cleaved so this
is rescue attic but it can provide the
eat a breakfast a can you get a new cell
so can rescue is a DCC ADCP activities
so it is a you vivo experiment so as a
Left panel you see the protea the also
type of control again says a tumor girl
but if you trade with the you tagged
antibody so do to map so the efficacy is
some repute a because this time we use
the cash a cell line that overexpress
the protease so the so that you buddy
Sajida mother actually got cleaved so
they have a partial efficacy but when
you construct tattoo to blab with the
pretty little resisted h that you say
you restore the [ __ ] set tumor inhibition
a user read panel so this time we uses
rescue anybody if you are if you take is
a the less credible you and by the
self-efficacy right because the logic is
hurtful receptor but if you are you give
it a you talk to a to to map with the
protein a to resist rescue anybody
you get the Wahab said tumor inhibition
so actually this time first time you've
ever study we know that the boss is a
tattoo to map proteolytic cleavages
reduces the former antibody can visit to
put in a cleavage give you walk said
tumor inhibition efficacy also the
rescue approach can't do the same so
this is a not published the picture to
show you that if you overexpress if you
overexpress forty Proteus hire her to
carousel lie you say the tumor goes so
much bigger and the suggesting that this
protein it little crevices of auto
antibody play a role either either
controlling of tumor goals this is the
pacific division of the so-called rest
humoral immunity so this also happens to
be the catcher celerity so this
experiment which know that the how high
to expression cassius airlines such as
kelvis ray as a capias apt for zoo for
so for Kerry was active on the other
hydrogen but there's a lower to
expression catch the zelda mm MSA for
several for example cannot so this
suggests is that the cleavage of
everybody need has a teapot actually
engage this the proximity to the
prakasha cell surfers everywhere put es
is like a piece a bulimic analogous
critical proteases but this stasis cell
matrix and violet cultural matrix
proteases and the cleavage of variety
but it's also also happens in the clinic
psyche in this case way this is a breast
cancer patient who's a hurtful positive
so say was treated with a stratagem a
new attribute for six months followed by
surgery and there they are
that idly by the title maperformance
patients a sample and to show that the
expressive Waheeda cleavage
means this patient show that validate is
at the hinge cleavage it doesn't happen
use clinical setting and your clinical
study we we took about over 100 Kasia
patients and a ratio the Proteus
cleavage or for antibodies is a curse is
a tumor samples but not a you normal
tissue and he's a panel if you can tell
that the cleavage of anybody's more
detectable tumor tissues not new plasma
as I told you earlier cleavage rattly
body actually needs anybody engaged
Cassius cell because the matrix protease
is another secreted the total plasma and
also you this exponent of the correlated
the expression of m18 i and so you say
everything i use a panel i of express
these tumor samples not a visa matched
normal tissue and the you penalty and
there is a strong correlation partial
correlation between MEP no expression at
this level for single hedge antibody
cleavage either you panel a we also
notice that the reproductive profession
title have a more active body cleavage
than the Yi are positive and PR positive
casual on how to part part of
discussions patients this my explains
why triple negative breast cashier very
aggressive cash attempts and so far
there is no good therapist for a triple
negative breast cancer and you panel P
we also preserve that the single head
clear everybody
our motor topologies a leaf node
metastasized breast caches air localized
tumor setting that the signal hit the
cleavage is associative is a tumor
progression and the metathesis also
Kalitta visa
Naveen I and other MLP expression and
the metathesis so to summarize what we
have learned here is that try to to map
you pod realize and if you say factor
function for the efficacy such as 86
it'll kill kills caches cell but a doula
tumor progression you have accumulation
of metalloproteases and sensor am a
piece this protease in such as a VP Naik
a cleave data to map the head region
this will compromise the SSA media the
effects of function have loss of a DCC
at the ADCP this led to Cassius el suavo
and leads result to attracted to memory
resistors so to talk to conclude the
daddy bodies festival susceptible to
limited the proteolytic cleavage in
tumamoc environment and the single
cleaver daddy buddy
demonstrate the user try to to web
example at the hydrogen red this is a
humid EG water type dysfunctional with
regard to cell killing functions such as
a GCC and a DCT and they will all we
have Auto antibodies that the coverage
cleaved anybody but that's not
sufficient to provide the cash informal
happening in you know in certain
populations so the idea of a
supplementation for either haider
al-abadi
immunity by vaccination or by drug drug
administration for appropriate
antibodies
that can restore sell clearest by trade
antibody could potentially became a
while both erotic options for both cash
and effects disease you need to use this
webinar I don't have time to talk about
the you know for after this this
potential application for for back to
infection but today we focus on Kesha
finally our what knowledge that this is
a collaboration PK univer Texas the
Texas century Institute and also my club
clinical collaborator dr. Annalise
Gonzales and also collaboration is the
judgment ashes who provide the funding
also as you know knowledge and in the
platform to make this possible and
family the funding sources for this
project so we said I knelt over to Kara
with applicants artists who will excuse
you some of the idea
I became antibody technologies great hi
everyone my name is Karan Sharma and I'm
a product manager for the rad mAb
antibody range here at AB cam firstly I
want to thank dr. Ahn for sharing his
research and presentation with us today
and while you're thinking of questions
to ask I wanted to take a few moments to
talk about the rad mad antibody platform
which dr. Ahn utilized to develop the
novel antibodies discussed in this
presentation and how the same technology
may be useful for you the next time you
plan an experiment the main points of
antibody quality that we focus on our
specificity sensitivity and consistency
I want to go through each of these
points and share with you how we address
them through novel technologies
platforms and techniques
so the first one we'll start with is
specificity we select the most
appropriate application based on the
particular protein targeted and we use a
combination of approaches to ensure the
specificity of our antibodies our
standard screening and validation
program includes Eliza's western blot
immuno precipitation
immunohistochemistry immuno Saito
chemistry and flow cytometry testing we
then supplement these validations with
more powerful techniques like IP mass
spectrometry peptide array testing and
gene editing technologies we are
constantly searching for better methods
to evaluate specificity and we've
continued to adopt more advanced
technologies as they become available an
example of one of these adoptions is the
use of knockout cell lines provided by
horizon discovery the knockout
initiative relies on CRISPR cast 9
generated human knockout cell lines that
allow for a haploid cellular model and
offer a true negative control with which
to test antibody specificity haploid
models are easier to generate then
modified diploid cell lines as only one
allele needs to be targeted to obtain a
loss-of-function phenotype we grade
these knockout samples at Western blot
with the following results first one is
specific which means that their signal
in the wild-type and not in the knockout
samples second is recognizing the target
alongside other proteins this is where
the signal is in the wild-type and not
in the knockout samples at the region of
interest but there is signal observed in
both samples at various molecular
weights and then thirdly on specific
this is where there is no or limited
reduction of signal in the knockout
compared to the wild type temple at the
region of interest all of this data is
uploaded to the individual data sheets
of the products and onto our public
website and the bodies that are specific
or recognize their target alongside
other proteins remain available for our
customers on specific antibodies are
removed from the catalog and our
customers are notified
right now Western blot is our primary
validation method ICC testing is also
carried out where as you see is deemed
important to the antibody or protein
target the next point in antibody
quality is sensitivity rabbit monoclonal
antibodies are generated on the same
principles as
Bonnell quarrels but take advantage of
the rabbits ability to mount an immune
response against a much broader range of
compounds the rabbit immune system
optimizes affinity by mechanisms that
are more efficient than those of mice
and other rodents rabbits can be used to
produce these high affinity antibodies
even against antigens that are not
immuno genic and mice on average we've
seen that rabbit monoclonal antibodies
have 10 to 100 times higher affinity for
a target antigen than mouse monoclonal
antibodies rabbit antibodies are also
better at distinguishing subtle
differences such as epitope variations
select modifications mutations and
conformational changes due to the larger
and more diverse B cell repertoire rat
mad antibodies also combine the best
properties of monoclonal with the most
desirable attributes of rabbit
polyclonal antibodies the figure on the
right shows serial sections of human
tonsil tissue where IHC was performed in
Figure a a leading mouse monoclonal
against ki-67 we used on this issue at a
1 to 200 dilutions in Figure B our
rabbit monoclonal against ki-67 was used
at a 1 to 1000 dilution as you can see
at a higher dilution you still get
higher sensitivity with the rabbit
monoclonal antibody after we have
confirmed specificity and the
appropriate sensitivity for a particular
assay we need to make sure that these
results remain consistent to generate a
recombinant antibody genes encoding the
antibody heavy and light chains can be
cloned into a vector that will permit
their expression and more robust host
cell lines from here the resulting
recombinant antibodies can be isolated
and purified just as though they had
been produced using a hybridoma one
sequence recombinant antibodies are not
subject to loss of activity caused by
sequence drift or loss of yield both of
which can affect hybridomas if they are
poorly maintained once an antibody has
been cloned recombinant antibody
production provides a scalable fully in
vitro system to consistently produce
antibodies that are identical from batch
to batch
the engineered nature of recombinant
antibodies also makes it easier to
improve both antibody specificity and
sensitivity if required more than 90% of
the rad maps on our catalog are
recombinant rabbit monoclonal does
offering improved sensitivity
consistency and reproducibility the
image on the right is IHC analysis of
human non small cell lung cancer tissue
stained with our rabbit monoclonal
against PDL one clone 28 8 in Figure a
this tissue is stained with just and
rabid monoclonal AGG isotype control
where we show no staining figures B
through F R of the won PDL one rabbit
monoclonal antibody but each figure is a
different batch of that clone and as you
can see the batches show consistent
sending results today we have over
10,000 recombinant rabbit monoclonal
antibodies on our catalog each of these
clones can be provided and customizable
buffer formulations and directly
conjugated formats we also provide
custom rad map services to over 700
universities institutes and companies
globally and have developed more than
300 clones for IHC pathology for those
researchers in the immune oncology field
we have many resources in the form of
webinars protocols posters and valid
reagents to learn more about these you
can visit WWF km calm
slash tag slash cancer an example of one
of these rabbit monoclonal antibodies
that has gone through each stage of the
antibody quality procedures is clone 28
8 anti human PDL 1 antibody this
antibody shows no cross reactivity with
PDL 2 and has been validated for use in
flow cytometry IHC and western blot the
clone has also been validated and
commonly used Auto spanners in addition
we have a full set of ancillary reagents
to use alongside clone 28 when carrying
out IHC or Western blot recombinant
rabbit monoclonal antibodies are
incorporated into each of our assay
technologies including
simple step Eliza's matched any body
pair kits and fire Plex immunoassays
simple step kits are validated with
relevant biological samples so you
notices will work with your specimens
and give Eliza results in just 90
minutes compared to the usual for our
standard time matched antibody pair kits
provide just the essential reagents
allowing you to use your own custom
protocols for Eliza based assays and
fire Plex immunoassays allow you to ask
a multiple proteins such as cytokines
simultaneously right down to the
picogram per mil concentration thank you
for listening please visit the following
links if you'd like to learn more about
anything discussed I'd like to now hand
it over to our moderator Jessica for any
questions that may have been received
wonderful thank you Karen and thank you
dr. Ahn for your presentations today a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them in
the Q&A box found by circling excuse me
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left hand side of
the presentation window dr. Ahn and
Curran will now answer as many questions
as time permits and current I'm already
seeing several questions in the queue
great ok dr. Ahn so the first question
is how would a vaccine approach work to
rescue the proteolytically cleaved
autoantibodies yes so it allowed you
that we have we have Auto antibodies
actually target e tumor so stategies
these antibodies is a part of every new
Sevilla's that prevent her culture from
happening so but is a these are these
antibodies sometimes not enough to - to
rescue or craved antibodies so what we
can do is for nikasha patients we can
immunize
the patients with the H cleaved peptides
as
peptide the water we hope is that the
river generate antibodies guess this
creepy decide so this is everybody these
are these humanization generated
antibodies will be able to rescue is the
cleavage autoantibodies this we are
other lives actually working this casual
Reina but rather how papers published
this actually works the imitation
project works either popular sections
that where this immunization can
generate antibodies
let's go clear anybody's - for staph
aureus infection okay and the next
question is can you inhibit the MMPs to
prevent anybody cleavage in the tumor
microenvironment yeah that's a good
question the I mean piece they have
value humans at least they have a 36
different any piece any piece they play
a primary very important of biological
physiological function normal function
of offers the mammalian system so you
have a she or any piece could have a
potential you know side effects and I'll
say that is a ma piece there's overlap
he activities is the vertical to
oscillate specific MMP inhibitors
you thought that use a medical field
that you know people have to try to make
a small molecule maybe inhibitors but
due to lack of a select specificity and
slug stimuli and this approach is not
very productive so that said there is a
push for actually generate the earthly
body inhibitors for specific game in
peace and i would imagine with vetted by
the technology are devices such as rabid
anybody from b-cell poor that we might
be able to get very unique specific
antibodies specifically for this
individual a main piece so that's the
protection evolving options yes okay and
the next question is also involving
as well are the MMPs in the tumor
microenvironment free in liquid phase
and extracellular space or on the tumor
cell membranes yeah as I discussed in my
lecture I mean he's a secret most
accredited approaches
accept WADA's mep 40 that's a memory bod
it was the could you to put here protein
ma be such an MHC several nice rate they
are actually stasis cell matrix that's
why they called matrix
metalloproteinases you can't detect mmm
please you circulation but it's a rural
concentration they're mostly not a
functional and this neutral you know
cell degradation products so that's why
you ever uh sure the wall experiment
that cleavage of antibodies you need to
have ready but actually attach to the
cell so i you that experiment really and
you recall if you keep you keep into
anybody with the cassius our lives that
overexpress hurtful such as bt for say
before is a KBS way you saw cleavage
comment padded cleavage anybody but if
you youtube into anybody with em safe
civilly that's a bread casual cell line
but another express her to that high
level they do not say cleavage so that
means the cleavage need to have that
people actually proximity are attached
to a cell or attached to a tumor surface
user user critical psyche and then the
next question is would there be any
negative effect of entirely suppressing
IgG paralysis
yeah I think if there is is that
everybody sick leave it at the head
rages now we do know evolutionarily is
as any advantage for for this mechanism
it could be just the sort of fact that
their energies in the tumor tissue is no
more tissue
that the variety but attached to the
tissue that got a cleaved that everybody
got degraded but I'm sure that if you
you have it entirely the put it in
cleavage the further MEP activities you
will have a side effects but as a
security approach we're proposing such
as such as a the backstreet approach to
generate a cleavage specific antibodies
to let's do the cleavage or
supplementation of antibodies that can
rescue the crib antibody will not cut
you Tolly are suppress the IgG
put your paralysis label so so so they
do they are forgiven us completely
shutdown system so to expect major side
effect but in Seville has been tested
the youth clinic as a security approach
to figure out exactly if this is a safe
or not okay and the next question is
what is the advantage of using in
anybody against the cleaved therapeutic
AB instead of engineering the
therapeutic antibody to be Proteus
resistant yeah that's a very good
question
so if there's two two types of active
bodies that we with the peda to help us
to to find a guest catcher why is
actually our natural immune system so we
have active bodies recirculation target
the tumor source identities so-called
alternative bodies we actually we cannot
identify anybody's targeting her - so
these deadly bodies are part of our new
surveillance system to overcome you know
but so these anybody's they another
resisted to cleavage so to rescue to
plus overall your new system so we can
give this rescue anybody as supplemental
to the system this is similar to the PP
one pjo wall video for MU inhibitory
receptor antibodies to put some fatty
cells so they said they'd give us a
mighty body to help to put our t-cells
the semi said here is the reality's
rescue anybody that can cut pushed our
auto everybody's you know immunity or
humoral immunity so these are other sort
of a color that is a very general
security but such as tattoo to map to
prefer the gas kasha results a key
magenta generator put it exist anybody
which I already showed you example and
so to summarize facility body the
engineer protein existed cleavage
antibody and a fourth rescues also added
body other oil new humoral immunity the
givers a rescue anybody okay and then
the next question is are all isoforms of
anybody's sensitive to mmp-9 yeah that's
a very good question actually the and
igv raw auto type is mostly effective to
put in a cleavage whatever our duty to
is less so this explains why this
probably is a already told you the H IgG
water type is a workhorse of our new
system to engage the ADC say a DCP you
know same assay cities say that for
bacteria clears fighting against
tumor cells from viruses so that's why
the head RGV wha H is the most of the
system to cleavage this is like the
Achilles heel so this is the patient is
the anybody you can imagine anybody
answer is such a large molecule where
you already have is not humane methods
that's a festival to all cuts a
political image in fact we know that
banker protease is regulated by these
age ranges and in there those put is the
various factors if you remove these
proteins from bacteria they no longer
become passages so so similar we
calculated tumor cells as a peculiar
they are passages tumor cells are not
normal so their packages so the tumor
cells to survive they need actually have
mechanisms to you made this antibody
immunity so therefore they publish
proteases which can target ipdois okay
and then i believe this is going to be
the final question of the webinar
why not alter the antibody sequence in
the hinge region yeah
so this is a simple question which
already I said so they actually already
Eugenie of this already published with
engineers acted by the hydrangeas
let's resist to all kinds of proteolytic
cleavage and you get this you have
example we're sure that if you give this
they have a catch a cell line that is
engineered to overexpress protein
proteases and you treat that to move
into a tumor for that poor and the
prisoners the tumor can try to be clever
you antibody so that you body give you a
partial efficacy because that elects
toast okay inhibitor how to signal II
but a very engineers resistive version
of Institute you map if the completely
resistant cleavage they give you the
walk said to my inhibition so that's
actually platform will hope it at
virtually would be camera I acted by the
also type which is a little head
cleavage may be used as a platform for
security but it's design wonderful thank
you so much doctor on and thank you
Curran if there are no more questions I
would just like to again once again
thank you for both in your presentations
doctrine do you have any final comments
new by Bucek you are you largest was the
wonderful questions they are very are
and is exactly what we hope didn't
approach my piled as the synthetic
approach I think as not only cash upon
infectious diseases maybe next time I
can talk about applications it's
approaching for fight infection
which n is equally excited at the
important asthma against the Kashyap
thank you so much for your time
wonderful thank you and I'd like to
thank the audience today for joining us
and for their interesting questions we'd
like to thank our sponsor AB camp for
underwriting today's agita excuse me
educational webcast as well at this time
a survey should have popped up on your
screen we would appreciate you taking
two minutes to answer the survey to help
us further plan future webinars for your
information this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through November 2017
bobrucz will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share the email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live webinar so with that I'd
like to thank you once again for joining
us today and good luck with your
research